in this video we'll talk about
apoptosis
the greek word apoptosis means
falling off apoptosis is one type of
programmed cell death
in apoptosis cells shrink and forms this
kind of blob like structures known as
apoptotic bodies
and there is an overall shrinkage of the
cell size
in this video we'll talk about what is
apoptosis classification of apoptosis
molecules which are associated with
apoptosis and how apoptosis can be
detected
sweptosis is a pathway which is highly
regulated and it's a suicide program
in this process the dying cell activates
several intrinsic enzymes that degrade
the cells on dna and nucleic and
cytoplasmic proteins so it's an auto
destruction program
apoptotic cells break into fragments
known as apoptotic bodies which are
later on taken up by specific phagocytes
it is important to note that the plasma
membrane of apoptotic cells
do not disintegrate the integrity of
membrane is maintained however the
composition of the membrane is altered
which attracts the phagocytes and it has
many other rules
so
these phagocytes take up these apoptotic
bodies or living cell
and thereby no inflammation is actually
created due to apoptosis and that's the
biggest signature feature of apoptosis
when compared to necrosis we would see
necrosis is often associated with
inflammatory response but apoptosis is
not
moreover there is no leakage of
cytoplasm during apoptosis whereas there
is leakage of cytoplasmic materials
during necrosis due to the loss of
membrane integrity
in a different video i have described
necrosis in bit more details so click on
the video in the i button or in the
description to learn more about necrosis
however in this video we are going to
focus on apoptosis
apoptosis can broadly be classified into
two subtypes
pathology associated apoptosis
which occurs during many infection
or many kind of like
kind of pathological situations
and physiological apoptosis occurs
during development
and actually apoptosis is a key
regulator of development
so let's try to understand how apoptosis
shapes up development and it's an
important process in human
physiology apoptosis could be found and
could be seen
during the time of digit
individualization all our digits are
actually combined
by via a pain membrane
and there are many cells which die in
during this development process and
thereby
separating the digits
at birth
that means apoptosis actually works like
a molecular sculpture artist who is
sculpting and revealing new structures
in the course of development similar
examples could be found in
morphogenesis of frog where the tadpole
tail is lost due to apoptosis or we can
see similar structure in human brain
development where a specific cell type
known as kahal rezia cells which are the
transient cell population they die
during the course of development and
before birth they should be dead
if they are forced to survive then there
are detrimental consequences
so that tells us death of certain cell
type is equally important like survival
in immunology we can also see in our
immune system especially in our lymph
node in the germinal center apoptosis is
going on very frequently
in the germinal center there are a lot
of immature b cells which are
trying to recognize antigen but their b
cell receptors might have a low affinity
towards antigen or a high affinity
towards an antigen if the affinity is
low then and there these cells are
eliminated via apoptosis
and there is no inflammation which is
evoked
and if the cell has high affinity then
they differentiate into specific plasma
cell
that means overall apoptosis is pretty
important for cellular physiology
let's talk about apoptosis happening in
pathological circumstances
first circumstance is dna break
dna break is pretty detrimental
and if double-stranded dna break cannot
be repaired apoptosis might be evoked
unrepaired dna break has harmful
consequences such as it can stall the
replication fork it can lead to loss of
the chromosome segment etc in this
extreme scenario when the defect cannot
be reversed then cell choose to die in a
regulated fashion via apoptosis and save
the cells in the surrounding
now apoptosis can also be caused due to
accumulation of misfolded protein and
this kind of theme is very common in
neurodegenerative diseases like
parkinson's alzheimer's etc in
parkinson's disease the new bodies are
actually aggregated proteins which
accumulate in specific neurons in the
substantia [ __ ] and these dopaminergic
neurons actually die in the parkinson
patients
now accumulation of too much of these
aggregates in the endoplasmic reticulum
causes the ear stress which ultimately
leads to the activation of apoptotic
programs and thereby killing the cell
now let us try to understand the
molecular pathways which is regulating
the apoptosis there are two different
pathways
which are most studied in context of
apoptosis one is intrinsic pathway which
involves the mitochondria another is
extrinsic pathway which does not
involve the mitochondria so in the
intrinsic pathway there are specific
sensors
and in the extrinsic pathway there are
specific receptors which bind to ligand
which are actually giving the signal for
apoptosis these receptors are fast
receptors which bind to fast ligand very
commonly found in immune system
tnf receptors which binds to tnfs
anyway these receptors interact with
several adapters which we are not
focusing right now but the
goal of these receptor ligand-mediated
interaction is to activate
initiator caspase
these initiator caspers get activated
or cleaved these cleaved initiator cache
space then can initiate a caspase
cascade and this cache space can
activate a ultimate executor caspase
most of the cases the executor caspase
is the caspase 3 so cleaved caspase 3
is now generated cleaved caspase 3 is
the hallmark for apoptotic cell and
cleft caspase 3 can cleave dna proteins
and many other things
now let's talk about the intrinsic
pathway there are several sensors which
can sense something is going wrong
inside the cell and the cell need to die
there are bcl two family sensors which
can sense this
several bcl to family regulators such as
backs bad all of these can poke holes in
the mitochondrial membrane which leads
to the leakage of cytochrome c
cytochrome c is involved in the electron
transport chain it should not be leaked
into the cytoplasm but when it leaks
into the cytoplasm that means something
is wrong and now apoptosis or auto
destruction program has to be triggered
cytochrome c interacts with other
molecules such as a puff one which
further activates
and accelerates the process of
caspase-3 cleavage
moral of the story
in both of these pathway they converge
at the state of
caspase-3 cleavage
caspase-3 is the executor caspase which
execute the process of apoptosis it
leads to
destruction of the dna fragmentation of
the dna it also leads to fragmentation
of other organelles ears
etc and ultimately it leads to bleeding
of the cell
and inside the blade we can have a
broken dna some organelles like
mitochondria lysosome etc ultimately
these blades would be projected out of
these cells
and that can be uptaken by specific
phagocytes
now this kind of scenario is pretty
common in case of viral infection
when there is a viral infection
the virus infects the particular cell
type
now this particular cell type
has a specific machinery known as class
1 mhc generation machinery
so some of these viral proteins are
actually degraded by the proteasome and
these degraded proteins are uptaken into
the er by a transporter known as step
one
this viral protein can be loaded onto
class 1 mhc molecule and the class 1 mhc
molecule bound
peptides can be displayed on viral
infected cells
this class 1 mhc molecule bound peptides
can signal cd8 positive cytotoxicular t
cells
cytodoxy killer t cells secrete specific
cytotoxic granule these granules contain
perforin and granzymes all these things
lead to apoptosis
so perforin
creates perforation or pores
and through this pores granzymes come
inside
now these granzymes can actually
activate bead or these bcl2 family
regulators which can poke hole in
mitochondria and let the cytochrome c be
released into the cytoplasm
now as we have discussed earlier
cytochrome c can interact with a puff
one activate
or activate the cleavage of the class
caspase 3 and thereby triggering
apoptosis
now there could be also interaction
between fast and fast l ligand
so these fast and fast ligand
interaction can trigger caspase-8
caspase-8 can be cleaved and further
cleave caspase-3 and thereby ultimately
evoking the program of apoptosis
and thereby the virus-infected cell dies
though this particular cell dies the
cells near the vicinity are saved
so apoptosis is an overall protective
mechanism during infection as well
so now we understood what is apoptosis
let's try to focus how one researcher
can detect apoptosis
now first of all a researcher can
perform
immunohistochemistry against cleaved
caspase-3 to understand whether the cell
is undergoing apoptosis or will undergo
apoptosis or not if there is a
accumulation of cleaved caspase-3 that
is highly indicative of that the cell is
undergoing apoptosis
now there are other labeling techniques
known as terminal
deoxynucleotide transferase or tdt nick
and
n labeling so this is known as tunnel
assay in this process uh this process is
based on the fact that the apoptotic
cell would have fragmented dna and there
are specific enzymes such as tdt
transferase this transference can
incorporate specific labeled dutp into
these dna and thereby marking the dna of
these apoptotic cells so here the
fluorescence present would ensure that
there is a bro there is significant
amount of broken dna in a cell
most likely that cell is undergoing
apoptosis there are other high
throughput techniques known as anexin 5
pi assay
5 pi assay is basically combined it's
basically a
acid which is combined with flow
cytometry the anexin 5 protein binds to
the exposed
phosphatidylserine on the membrane
now phosphatidylserine in the healthy
cells are often present in the inner
leaflet so they are never exposed to the
cytosolic site but in the apoptotic cell
it is exposed on the cytosinic side such
that
we can detect it via particular protein
binding so anexin 5 binds to this
phosphatidylserine in apoptotic cell
now
membrane lipid composition is
heterogeneous and there are several type
of membrane lipids that are present we
have to understand in
in case of apoptosis the membrane lipid
distribution dramatically changes for
example the phosphatidylserine which is
always present in the cytoplasmic side
now flips into the outer leaflet and
that's a characteristic signature and
this is exactly detected by annexin 5
which was actually an anticoagulant
protein and this binds
to phosphatidylserine with very high
affinity and this is taken care of using
flow cytometry because a conjugated
anexin 5 can be detected using flow
cytometry and that would tell us about
the status of apoptosis
and now propedium iodide is another dye
which gets inside the cell when there is
enough amount of um
so so enough amount of damage to the
cell it's a late state apoptosis marker
now if you want to learn details about
this anexin pi5 assay and how the flow
cytometry can be used to determine that
i have a separate video on that but
moral of the story is looking at the
facts data we can
understand whether the cell is at very
early stage of the apoptosis when uh we
don't see any
uh
signal due to
let's say a propedium iodide or annexin
5
it might be
viable cell it might be late stage
apoptosis or it could be also necrosis
in case of necrosis
there is no
anexin binding but there is propedium
iodide which leaks in so all these
signatures could be highly informative
for a scientist to understand whether
the cell is undergoing necrosis
apoptosis or the cell is viable at this
moment
now this is a little bit fast in terms
of understanding so you can watch the
video at a slower pace and it is the
link is provided in the i button anyway
in this video we looked at what is
apoptosis classification and we looked
at the molecular pathways which are
associated with apoptosis and we lastly
look at how apoptosis can be detected by
a scientist
i hope this was useful
but before we end this video let me tell
you in case of apoptosis there is no
secretion of cytokine and thereby no
inflammation is evoked but there are
other process known as necroptosis which
is a hybrid of apoptosis and necrosis
which can lead to robust inflammation by
secreting specific cytokines if you want
to learn more about necrosis again you
know how what to do you can go to the i
button or description to learn more
about necroptosis so necroptosis simply
means necrosis plus apoptosis it's a
hybrid of these two and this is highly
regulated as well unlike necrosis and
also there is a loss of atp swelling of
the cell ros generation and release of
lysozyme lysosomal enzymes which are
pretty characteristic of this particular
cell death you can get many notes and
flash cards regarding
several biology topics in my facebook
page instagram page all the links are
provided in the description you can
follow me on instagram and there are
specific mcq contests that is always
going on in my instagram page you can
participate in that instagram page and
win so last month winner was remy carroy
she has given the most number of correct
answers in the next month's contest
would have a prize this is a particular
custom designed coffee mug that you can
get all you have to do is go to my
second channel known as let's crack bio
exam and you have to answer the
questions daily put it in the comment
and like that particular community post
if you do it for 30 days the person who
gives the maximum number of current
correct answer would win
and he or she would get this particular
gift
anyway you can support my channel via
patreon you can also support me via
the super thanks option which is present
in the bottom right corner of the video
you can click on the super thanks option
and pay via net banking paytm paypal or
upi
see you in the next video all my social
media links are provided in the
description if you wish to connect feel
free i would be happy to help
see you in next video